[Music]
i was a high school teacher
for 19 years and then i became a
principal of an elementary school and
for the past two years i've been a
superintendent i want to get students
active and engaged and co-create their
learning experience with their teachers
and you can only do that when you have
the proper tools and skills i'm also
doing another certification with another
university and they had a module on
design thinking and i said okay this i
can bring to my board and i got really
energized by that so i decided to
look up design thinking certification
programs i said i wonder if stanford
offers a certification program and i
went to stanford because they're the
best they had founded this concept in
this program so why would you not go
back to the source
i completed the creativity and design
thinking and it was one of the best
programs i've ever experienced it's
really hands-on
and we need more of that as adult
learners and because of that i feel more
confident and i can't wait to bring that
to my colleagues and i think design
thinking helps us be a bit lighter but
productive at the same time and being of
service to our students in our school
community if you want to step away from
the traditional
boring
unproductive meetings and you want to
try something that's fresh and active
you're going to want to try design
thinking
[Music]